Hey, what's up guys? Now in yesterday's video I pulled a request out of the comments to make a silicone mold of a real heart.
So I decided to give it a try,
I made a wooden box, and mixed up a new batch of silicone and poured it over top of a pigs heart, and let it set over night.
Now the rubber is firm, so lets cut it open, clean up the mold
and fill it up with candy melts to make our self a real chocolate heart for Valentines Day.
Alright all the screws on the bottom have been removed so we should be able to pry this thing up now
but it seems like silicone grabs on a lot harder to wood than it does to acrylic.
Ohh yes look at that!
there is the bottom of the heart you can actually see the hole where the screw went in
and held it in place
That is lovely.
Alright, lets go ahead and get this thing the rest of the way out
There we go
And that, hopefully, will be our little rubber heart mold
Now, before I cut into this, I need to think it through a little bit.
How do we want to cut this, because it is gonna leave seams
And I don't want the seams to go down the front of the heart
I'd rather have them around the back
There's so many parts to this heart, though,
And I'm under the impression that silicon has probably seeped inside it
So, uh, we may have to do a little bit of surgery
once we start digging down inside
It always amazes me how tough and rubbery this stuff is
I always like cutting at a criss cross angle, a jagged angle
because that helps the final mold come out a little bit better
Oops, I cut off part of my glove
We have a little bit of silicon in here that slipped into all those cracks and crevices
but we don't really want those in our finished product
so I just sliced them off
There we go!
Our heart is recovered
and its looking in a really good shape
And I'm feeling pretty confident we got ourselves a pretty good looking mold here
So we're gonna take this thing and save it for later
And now what we need to do is clean and sterilize our mold
and prep it for use with chocolate
Look at all the different flaps and folds that are in there
Like just looking at it, it makes absolutely no sense whatsoever
But we do need to clean it, because there's like little gross bits of heart
So how does it smell?
It does have a very faint odor of formaldehyde
So we're going to take some hot, soapy water and some bleach
So we can clean and sterilize this thing
and prep it for use with chocolate
It's already smelling fresher!
Now we're gonna put on a little bit of bleach to sterilize that a little bit more
Give one more wash then rinse it off, and it should be good to go
There we go!
Clean, sterilized, just needs a good rinse now
and we should be good to pour our chocolate.
Alright, so, update guys
we have successfully removed our heart
and we cleaned and sanitized our rubber mold
We now have a heart mold, ready for casting chocolate.
So now we can throw all this stuff in the microwave
fill this up with chocolate,
and then let it set in the fridge for a few hours
So we can open it up and reveal the solid chocolate heart that lies inside
Now one thing that we have to keep in mind is
this heart is facing down
and I don't want one front layer to all be the same color
So when we pour in the different colors, I think I'm gonna drip it at different angles
and kind of smear it around a little bit
Hopefully that'll give it a bit more marbled effect
rather than a stacked layered effect
It already is starting to make a little bit of a marbled effect in there
If you were to look close, you would see
This is fun
Valentine's crafts King of Random style
And of course, if you're not making a mess, you're probably not having fun
and we are definitely having fun
Alright, let's get this thing to the fridge and give it a few hours to set
Now, our chocolate heart's been sitting in the fridge for a little over four hours
which isn't nearly as long as I would like to keep it in there
But we're running out of time
so let's go take it out
open the silicon mold,
and see what kind of results we got
Okay, so moment of truth guys.
Let's slowly and very carefully peel this thing open
so we can check out the results of our labors
Look inside there, it kinda looks like one of those magic mushrooms from Mario
and the red and white splotches
Oh, it's like having your first baby
Ha Ha Ha Ha
Check that out
Oh my goodness
That looks
Disturbingly
amazing
Yeah, actually that really does look - I'm proud of this, I'm proud of this chocolate heart
That looks crazy!
So anatomically correct
Come check this out
We got the ventricles, we got the atriums, we have the aorta
Everything's there, even these little flappy muscle things
I don't really know what purpose those serve, but
they're very delicate
And I imagine they taste fairly good
Everything about this looks cool
from every different angle
I'm loving it
I'm so glad we did this!
I heart you, internet
That looks amazing
I'm really, really proud of this chocolate heart
And it actually looks relatively edible as well
I mean, I thought it was gonna come out looking kinda gross,
because you could actually see the veins,
the division lines,
you could see the little contours of the muscle
and even these little ripples and folds
but, because of the pink
the white
and the Valentine's colors
I think it actually looks relatively edible
Okay, so now the biggest question on my mind is how much does this thing actually weigh?
we got it set to grams
and it comes out
1.1 kilograms
that is a healthy sized heart
Of course ironically enough,
this much sugar isn't good for your heart
The thing is absolutely massive!
So the question now is
how do these things actually taste?
And we got these weird little muscle looking things
On top of the atriums
I'm not really sure what they're for,
or what they're called, but
I think I can just snap it right off
Here we go
Look at that!
Oh and look inside
you can see that there's different layers to the chocolate too, that's kinda cool
You're playing with my heart, man.
Alright so how does this thing taste?
This is the moment of truth!
Just tastes like white chocolate
That's really fun!
Really fun, really cool
and it's got layers
How does it taste?
Good! I like it
You getting any heart flavor seeping through there?
Mm-mm It's choclate
So I'm not really sure who you'd give a heart like this to,
maybe someone who's aspiring to be a doctor,
or a mortician
I don't know
But, there you go
a 1 kilogram
anatomically correct
chocolate heart for Valentines Day.
So thanks to you, Andrew Jenson, for your comments,
you're the crazy kid that made this happen.
And I'm sending 25 dollars your way.
And to the rest of you,
thanks for joining me for this experiment,
have a happy Valentines Day,
and I'll see you in the next video
Talk to you then
That looks so cool!
[heart beating noises]
It's alliiiiiiive!